leur démission pour canal+ que vous
verrez très prochainement merci à
l'autre public à c'était sympa pendant
la pub il s'est passé des tas de choses
super intéressantes et j'aimerais
d'ailleurs lancé un petit appel à celui
qui passe la musique pendant la pub je
t'attends sur le parking pour te
défoncer la gueule car à chaque fois que
c'est moi j'ai le droit des titres qui
commence difficilement dans les années
soixante dix et des fous ici on va
mettre une nouveauté il met ainsi des
années 80 j'en ai marre je vais écouter
des trucs d'aujourd'hui moi aussi et
puis et puis il y à notre eric mendez
qui a fait joujou avec le public ça peut
leur jouer alors il va revenir au milieu
de la piste là et va montrer aux
téléspectateurs
[Applaudissements]
merci
voilà alors c'est super mais c'est juste
insupportable pour nous parce que ça
nous met les oreilles comme serre et
qu'il faut plus faire ça moi mais bon il
aime alors eric mendez et ils ont bien
raison